another terrorist released early from
prison bent on violence like the London
Bridge attacker shot dead on the streets
of London
prison certainly hadn't D radicalized
either of them it may have made matters
worse
he in action s'en conducted an
independent review of islamist extremism
in prisons in 2015 well if you wanted to
invent an incubator for violent
extremism you couldn't really do better
than the prison system at the minute
it's already beset with multiple
problems are washed with drugs violence
is hitting record highs you've got
highly charismatic offenders mostly
imprisoned under the Terrorism mic and
they're in very close proximity with
highly credulous violent young man if
prison life has that impact will longer
sentences help and at the next stage
mandatory parole boards are not always a
guaranteed safety net they're still
concerned about those like Sudesh a man
who on the face of it hadn't shown
themselves to be violent a fundamental
question here what to do if someone
poses a risk but can't be dealt with by
the criminal justice system because they
haven't committed and lock them up and
throw away the key offense ensuring that
they're not released early certainly
delays the problem but does it only
delay the problem what else is going to
change by locking them up for longer
this former chief prosecutor is calling
for a different approach longer prison
sentences will keep us safe a little bit
longer but that new it is that when they
come out they will be as radical as they
were when they went in as extreme as
they were when they went in and wanted
to do what they were planning to do
months years before but what about D
radicalization programs the prime
minister says often they don't work
and if Kedah who used to work on
programs guiding people from jail back
into the community says they do work but
have been cut back I would say that you
know what Boris Johnson said about that
they don't work I would disagree with
that he needs to go back and look at the
system and look at what worked in the
past because they have worked you know
speak to some of the guys that were
information and willing norms you know
and they will argue that a lot of them
have worked but for now government focus
seems to be on keeping them behind bars
for longer
Jason Farrell Sky News